in den 2030 soll es soweit sein
bis dahin will die nasa in der lage sein
menschen auf den mars zu bringen
das private raumfahrtunternehmen spacex
um ihre maske plant bereits für 2022
eine erste transport mission zum mars
und will sogar schon 2024 die ersten
menschen auf dem roten planeten bringen
und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind gehen
wir doch noch gleich einen schritt
weiter das ziel des raumfahrtprogramms
der vereinigten arabischen emirate ist
es bis 2100 17
eine sich selbst versorgende kolonie auf
dem mars zu gründen und stehen also ein
paar spannende jahre bevor und an
ambitionierten zielen und ehrgeiziger
forschung mangelt ist bei der besiedlung
des mars nun wirklich nicht und trotzdem
scheinen uns zumindest eine sache noch
probleme zu bereiten von den führenden
raumfahrtunternehmen eigentlich eine
menge haben sollten das geld viele
masken schätzte in einem tweet wo auch
sonst dass der bau einer ersten maßstab
irgendwo zwischen schlappen 100
milliarden bis zehn billionen us dollar
liegen wird
wieviele es genau wird das sei davon
abhängig was wir alles zu mars
mitbringen müssen
denn viel gewicht ins weltall zu
transportieren ist teuer aber wie wäre
es wenn wir einfach ohne gepäck zum mars
fliegen würden
wie das funktionieren soll und welche
technologie dahinter steckt das erklären
wir heute bei doktor watson und vergesst
nicht im kanal zu abonnieren um keine
neuen videos zu verpassen
[Musik]
der mann dessen ziel es ist menschen
quasi nur mit handgepäck auf den mars zu
schicken ist der physiker in görschen
fällt vom team
er ist dort leiter des center of bits
and adams und vorstand verschiedenen
bereichen des physical computing
fashion-fans idee ist eigentlich ganz
simpel
was wäre wenn wir die technologie für
eine maß station nicht von der erde zum
mars transportieren müssen sondern sie
einfach vor ort herstellen könnten
klingt ziemlich futuristisch und
erinnert ein bisschen an die möglichkeit
aus star trek
okay ganz so einfach wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht werden aber wie
könnte so ein echter replicator aussehen
wir können ja nicht einfach dinge
entstehen lassen wo vorher keine waren
oder die letzten jahre hat gefällt er
sich dem bereich des physical computing
gewidmet er wollte herausfinden wie die
virtuellen berechnungs möglichkeiten von
computern in der physischen realität
eingesetzt werden können
dabei lag sein fokus vor allem darauf
wie wir mit digitalen bauplänen reale
objekte herstellen können
da denkt man natürlich schnell an 3d
drucker doch nicht nur die auch
maschinen wie laser scanner oder cnc
fräsen könnten laut görschen fällt in
der zukunft eine wichtige rolle spielen
seiner meinung nach stehen wir nämlich
vor einer dritten digitalen revolution
wir hatten bereits die digitalisierung
von daten und die entwicklung eines
personal computers und die
digitalisierung von kommunikation über
das internet
die dritte stufe in der wir uns jetzt
gerade befinden ist die digitalisierung
der fabrikation und am ende dieser
revolution steht dann laut burschen
fällt der personalrat locator war sie
wie aus star trek ein werkzeug das im
grunde genommen alle bereits vorhandenen
maschinen und gegenstände selbst
herstellen kann
damit wäre theoretisch jeder mensch in
der lage fast alles selbst herzustellen
egal wo man sich gerade auf der welt
befindet
wir müssen nicht mehr in ungeliebten
jobs arbeiten um geld zu verdienen und
uns benötigte dinge kaufen
stattdessen wären dörfer und städte in
der lage sich selbst zu versorgen da
technologie und maschinen einfachen
selbst produziert werden könnten
die gedanken die gleichen fächer
anschlüssen sind ziemlich revolutionär
leider muss man aber auch dazu sagen
dass eine umsetzung in der form nicht so
einfach möglich sein wird und man
spätestens wenn man lizenzen kaufen muss
auch erneut geld zahlen müsste
und auch die materialien für die
gegenstände müssen ja irgendwo herkommen
kostenlos einfach alles zu drucken wird
also nicht drin sein
grundsätzlich gehen die gedanken aber
schon in die richtige richtung ein
system das sich selbst mit technologie
und materialien versorgen kann
und so nicht nur auf teure lieferungen
von außen angewiesen ist wäre nämlich
genau das was wir auf dem mars bräuchten
und die idee an sich ist überhaupt nicht
neu
eigentlich ist sie sogar schon ein paar
milliarden jahre alt seine inspiration
hat gehört mir fällt nämlich vom aufbau
und der herstellung von proteinen in
tieren pflanzen und pilzen proteine
werden während der sogenannten protein
biosynthese oder auch transaktionen
gebildet das ganze passiert an den
ribosomen die unter anderem im
zytoplasma unserer zellen umher
schwimmen
dabei benutzten ribosome die in der
messenger rna also m rna gespeicherten
genetischen informationen um aminosäuren
zu proteinen zusammen zu setzen
insgesamt besteht unser körper aus über
100.000 unterschiedlichen proteinen
durch die alle strukturen und funktionen
unserer zellen festgelegt werden und das
faszinierende ist dass diese 100.000
proteine aus nur 20 verschiedenen
sogenannten protein o genen aminosäuren
bestehen wenn man es also vereinfacht
herunterbricht bestehen die komplexen
motoren unseres körpers aus theoretisch
nur 20 bauteilen und genau das ist der
knackpunkt der idee deutschen feld sieht
nämlich die möglichkeit dass ich genau
das auch mit komplexen maschinen und
technologien erreichen lässt
die technologische version der
aminosäuren kann man sich quasi
vorstellen wie molekulares lego genau
wie bei den aminosäuren ergibt sich die
komplexität der zusammensetzung dann
nicht durch 1000 unterschiedliche teile
sondern der zusammensetzung einer
begrenzten anzahl an teilen und wie bei
lego gibt es klare regeln auf welche
arten und weisen mann so genannte nano
blogs zusammensetzen kann
dadurch können grobe fehler in der
zusammensetzung verhindert werden und es
ist möglich die teile am ende wieder
auseinander zu bauen und anderweitig zu
verwenden
das ziel ist es also den aufbau von
maschinen so zu vereinfachen das die
kleinste ebene auch so 20 verschiedenen
teilen bestehen kann
die nano blogs wären dann leitend
isolierende halbleitende und würden sich
zu winzigen schaltkreisen zusammensetzen
so bilden die nano blogs zusammen micro
blogs die dann neue eigenschaften haben
und immer so weiter
auf diese weise setzt sich das ganze
system nach und nach zusammen die
einteilung des aufbaus orientiert sich
dabei auch am vorbild der natur wie bei
proteinen besteht die erste ebene die
primär struktur aus dem coach der sich
durch die anordnung der nano blogs oder
eben der aminosäuren ergibt die zweite
ebene ist an die sekundär struktur und
beschreibt wie sich aus dem nahen u blox
die funktionalen elemente in mikroblogs
zusammensetzen aus diesen entstehen in
der tertia struktur module mit
speziellen aufgaben aus denen dann
wiederum in der kva struktur die
komplexen systeme hervorgehen jetzt
stellt sich natürlich trotzdem die frage
welche vorteile hat man davon und wie
soll man so gewicht einsparen
um diese frage zu beantworten ist es
wichtig sich einmal anzusehen wie genau
die zusammensetzung der nano box
funktionieren soll
deutschland fällt und sein team arbeiten
dafür eine art winzigem konstruktions
roboter dieser wird es ambler genannt
und soll in der lage sein die nano blogs
zu mikro blogs zusammenzusetzen und das
praktische die us-händler bestehen aus
denselben teilen mit denen sie arbeiten
dadurch ist es möglich dass sie wiederum
neue sampler herstellen die dann
gemeinsam immer mehr micro blogs
herstellen und so immer schneller immer
größere strukturen schaffen können
dadurch könnten teile für raketen oder
unterkünfte einfach auf dem mars an ort
und stelle produziert werden ohne dass
dafür riesige maschinen oder große
mengen unterschiedlicher materialien
benötigt würden durch die beschränkung
auf nur 20 unterschiedliche kleinste
einheiten müssen auch für computer oder
maschinen nicht mehr tausende
verschiedene resisto typen aus einer
vielzahl von materialien produziert und
zum mars geschickt werden
stattdessen könnte man bei der
produktion hauptsächlich auf materialien
zurückgreifen die bereits auf dem mars
verfügbar wären
mit diesem konzept will görschen fällt
vor allem zwei dinge erreichen
zum einen will er das in der produktion
nicht nur die pläne sondern auch die
bausteine selber digital werden
das bedeutet man sollte nicht mehr
darauf angewiesen sein das zur
herstellung großer geräte auch große
maschinen benötigt werden
die informationen sollen nicht mehr von
einem computer zum beispiel an einen 3d
drucker weitergegeben werden der sie in
eine analoge form übersetzt stattdessen
sind die infos über die verbindungen der
bausteine in diesen bausteinen selber
gespeichert genau wie bei lego steinen
die man ja auch nur auf eine bestimmte
art und weise zusammen stecken kann
die händler haben dann wiederum die
pläne für die größere konstruktion so
können die nur wenige hundert nanometer
großen bausteine effizienter
zusammengesetzt werden sein zweites ziel
ist es die produktion generell
ortsunabhängig zu machen dann könnte man
überall auf der welt und eben auch auf
dem mars alle möglichen maschinen
herstellen so lange man die 20
grundbausteine zur verfügung hat
computer rechenzentren und das gesamte
technische equipment für
forschungsstationen oder eben auch
maschinen zum bau von gebäuden oder
sogar raketen könnten dann einfach auf
dem mars selber hergestellt werden
coesfeld und sein team haben übrigens
schon mit der nasa zusammen gearbeitet
dabei wurde ein flugzeugflügel
entwickelt der aus ganz vielen kleinen
kohlenstofffaser partikeln besteht
die bauteile sind aufgebaut wie kleine
blöcke die durch ihre bauart sehr leicht
ineinander greifen
durch die verwendung vieler kleine
einzelteile ist es möglich die
aerodynamik eigenschaften des flügels
anzupassen und das sogar während des
fluges
außerdem fällt die schwere hydraulik weg
mit der man sonst große teile des
flügels bewegen müsste so spart eine
menge gewicht und auch die produktion
soll deutlich günstiger und schneller
möglich sein
das liegt daran dass eben nur eine
begrenzte zahl unterschiedlicher
bauteile benutzt wird
der nächste schritt ist jetzt sampler zu
entwickeln die die kohlenstofffaser
partikel selbstständig zu flügeln
zusammenbauen können und das ist
tatsächlich die schwierigste aufgabe von
allen denn wenn man das mal nicht dann
betrachtet ist die idee eines komplett
autonomen replicator doch noch etwas
realitätsfern
immerhin müssen wir dazu erstmal die
baupläne für alle nötigen geräte in
diesem neuen coach übersetzen
dann müsste man sicherstellen dass die
20 grundbausteine größtenteils aus
ressourcen vom mars hergestellt werden
können mal ganz abgesehen davon dass die
sampler wirklich in der lage sein
müssten die nano blogs völlig autonom zu
den richtigen micro blogs
zusammenzusetzen und so weiter bisher
gibt es von gefällten noch keine
einschätzung wann die technologie so
weit sein soll dass man sie wirklich
praktisch auf dem mars einsetzen kann
es kann also sehr gut sein dass wir
bereits mit dem bau einer mars basis
begonnen haben werden bevor die
technologie wirklich ausgereift ist
das bedeutet aber wiederum auch dass wir
andere wege finden müssen um zumindest
eine erste maß basis möglich und
finanzierbar zu machen
und wer weiß vielleicht hilft uns ja
dann eines tages der replicator dabei
aus der basis eine ganze kolonie zu
machen
zum glück wird jetzt schon mit hochdruck
daran gearbeitet die besiedlung des mars
mit aktueller technologie möglich zu
machen
es geht unter anderem darum geeignete
materialien zu finden aus denen eine
leicht zu transportierende maß basis
gebaut werden könnte ein material das
sie eine große rolle spielen könnte ist
graphen aus dem super dünnen und
leichten material lassen sich nanoröhren
formen die unglaublich stabil sind und
dabei trotzdem form bleiben
wenn ihr mehr darüber erfahren wollt
dann schaut euch gerne mein video dazu
hier oben an
da habe ich über graffin gesprochen und
was daraus alles machbar ist eine
weitere möglichkeit sind 3d gedruckte
gebäude über die ich in diesem video
schon gesprochen habe
damals ging es darum eine mondbasis doch
dasselbe prinzip sollte theoretisch auch
mit mars staub möglich sein um die
ersten menschlichen marsianer jedoch
auch vor der gefährlichen hoch
energetischen strahlung zu schützen hat
die nasa sogenannte mars holmes
konzipiert diese bestehen aus einer
leicht zu transportierenden aufblasbaren
hülle die einfach mit wasser gefüllt
wird das wasser in der höhe wird dann
mit materialien aus der mars oberfläche
vermischt gefroren und wird dann als
natürlicher schutz gegen die kosmische
strahlung damit das wirklich
funktionieren kann brauchen wir auf dem
mars vor allem eins wasser
auch wenn bereits gefrorenes wasser auf
dem mars entdeckt wurde sind diese
quellen nur sehr schwer zugänglich
die ersten besucher auf dem mars werden
also wahrscheinlich zunächst auf andere
optionen zurückgreifen müssen
und auf dauer immer einige kästen wasser
mit hoch zu schleppen ist leider keine
davon
wissenschaftler der university of
california in berkley haben aber bereits
eine mögliche alternative entwickelt es
ist eine art solarbetriebener wasser
filter der filtert das wasser mit hilfe
eines metal organic frameworks einfach
aus der luft das ganze funktioniert
schon auf eine luftfeuchtigkeit von 20%
und da die feuchtigkeit in der
atmosphäre des mars nachts zwischen 80
und 100 prozent liegen kann stehen die
chancen ganz gut dass das ganze auch
dort funktioniert den wissenschaftlern
ist es bereits gelungen innerhalb von
zwölf stunden drei liter wasser aus der
luft zu filtern und weil diese
entwicklung nicht nur auf dem mars
großen anklang finden könnte arbeiten
sie nun daran eine kostengünstigere
version für trockene gebiete hier auf
der erde zu entwickeln
auch wenn der beginn der mars
besiedelung noch ein paar jahre dauern
wird forschen wissenschaftler bereits
mit hochdruck an passenden technologien
ich finde es auf jeden fall super
spannend dass ich diesen nächsten großen
schritt der menschheit
höchstwahrscheinlich miterleben werde
und wer weiß vielleicht kommt der
personalrat kette jedoch schon etwas
früher als gedacht
wenn jetzt noch mehr darüber erfahren
wollt wie eine mögliche basis auf dem
mars aussehen könnte dann kann ich euch
der marsianer empfehlen kennen
vielleicht viele schon mit matt damon
als film allerdings wie so oft ist das
buch noch einmal in meinen augen ein
bisschen besser weil es noch viel mehr
in die tiefe geht es gibt viel mehr
details es gibt mehr berechnungen man
hört die inneren monologe von
hauptcharakter und ich finds ein sehr
cooles buch der sich tatsächlich schon
ich glaube drei oder vier mal komplett
durch gehört habe als per buch und zwar
auf wenn ihr euch dieses verbucht
runterladen möchte dann könnt ihr jetzt
komplett kostenlos machen indem ihr euch
einen account erstellt für die ersten 30
tage dann bekommt ihr ein hörbuch gratis
und wenn ihr den link unten in der video
beschreibung verwendet dann helft ihr
damit auch noch mal im kanal
damit erstellt ihr euch einen 30 tage
test account und selbst wenn der
ausläuft da könnt ihr noch das erste
hörbuch was ihr euch kostenlos
downloaden könnt behalten wenn ihr bei
diesem thema immer auf dem laufenden
sein wollt dann folgt uns gerne auf
instagram ex doktor watson da posten wir
jeden tag spannende science news und
ganz oft gibt es da auch um weltall
themen besonders nasa space ex mars und
mond und falls etwas 19 personen
replicator geben sollte dann kommst mir
das auch auf jeden fall auf instagram
ansonsten findet ihr hier das video zum
thema graffin wovon ich schon gesprochen
habe und hier unten geht es um die frage
warum brauchen wir wissenschaft denn man
kann sich die frage stellen warum bauen
wir eine super teure maß basis wenn wir
doch hier auf der erde noch probleme
haben
die gelöst werden müssen die frage
beantworte ich in dem video
ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen bleibt neugierig bleibt gesund
patrick